joining me now a small business owner
one who attended the protest against
Michigan's stay at home order today Matt
Seeley is a volunteer with the Michigan
conservative coalition Matt your
governor essentially said today that
you'd be stuck in the house anyway
because there's snow on the ground the
late snowstorm in Michigan it responds
to that it's just ridiculous
I mean ultimately everyone that came out
is so fed up with being sequestered and
treated like small children and that we
can't social distance and be diligent
about personal hygiene follow CDC
guidelines and state practices and you
know we want to take our lives back one
thing that we've learned through this is
that this is going to be the new normal
kovat 19 is going to be in our lives for
at least the next year or until there's
a vaccine and we need to figure out a
way to get back to as normal of a life
as possible while this plays out in the
background
the solution is have to lock us into our
homes well I'll say if you say when we
get a vaccine it always amazes me to
hear people say when we get a vaccine we
don't have an HIV vaccine we didn't
complete a SARS vaccine so the idea that
there's definitely going to be a vaccine
that's an incredibly involved process
necessarily so and it may or may not
happen but meanwhile governor Whitmer is
saying that what you did and had
thousands of people there it was just a
political stunt check it out it wasn't
really about the state a home order at
all it was essentially a political rally
a political statement that flies in the
face of all of the science all the best
practices and in the stay home order
that was issued a small group of people
that came together without masks on
brandishing their weapons who were
having you know posters of being
anti-choice this was a political rally
she says its political and suddenly
suddenly she starts bringing up an
teacher I mean I don't understand that
but is there any fairness to that
criticism that it wasn't a bipartisan
group of people it was basically just a
bunch of Republicans lying to make her
look bad no in fact we went out of our
way to make this bipartisan this is not
a political issue to us we would have
come out and had the same protest with a
Republican governor or an independent
governor we just think that our civil
liberties are being violated and decided
that the only way that we get our voices
be heard was to engage in basic civil
disobedience and you know we had a lot
of unity there were over 10,000 vehicles
we had over 600 trucks from the
construction industry including cement
haulers we had people from the
landscaping industry eating and cooling
we had boats down the toad so we gotta
go Matt we gotta go but we're seeing
signs of life in the American public
because there are a lot of us who were
out there saying look in the States
especially the ones that had very
relatively few infections compared to
what was being projected these people
are dying out there small businesses are
dying people are missing surgeries
people are having to take pay cuts in
the in the field of medicine because all
non-essential surgeries are being put
off there's a lot of pain out there that
has been overlooked and I think
including by your governor Matt thank
you so much great to see you tonight
and my